[Música]
sigue la expectativa por el control del
senado estadounidense Arizona es uno de
los estados donde continúa el conteo de
los votos allí la espera por los
resultados del Condado de maricopa está
retrasando la elección y las autoridades
dijeron que no terminarán antes del
viernes
miles de peruanos marcharon por el
centro histórico de Lima la capital del
país para exigir el cierre del Congreso
y rechazar el intento de una tercera
moción de vacancia contra el presidente
Pedro Castillo la llamada toma de Lima
terminó en disturbios Tenemos reporte
desde la capital peruana
por primera vez desde que asumió el
cargo el presidente de Chile Gabriel
borich visitó la región de la araucanía
epicentro del conflicto entre el estado
chileno y el pueblo mapuche por el
histórico reclamo de sus tierras Tenemos
reporte desde Santiago
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en francés 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Estados Unidos
porque sigue el conteo de los votos tras
las elecciones de medio término los
funcionarios electorales del Condado de
maricopa el condado más grande del
estado de Arizona y uno de los más
diputados de estos comicios indicaron
que aún faltan por contar entre 400.000
y 410 mil boletas y que no terminarán
hasta el viernes los funcionarios dieron
a conocer un recuento preliminar que
computa unas 62.000 34 boletas
adicionales del total hasta el momento
dicha cantidad favorece levemente a los
candidatos demócratas se trata del
recuento de boletas anticipadas
recibidas por las autoridades del
Condado durante el fin de semana hay
expectativa por el recuento de Voto en
ese condado debido a que hubo problemas
de impresión en 60 centros de votación
que impedían que los votos fueran
pasados a través de los tabuladores el
hecho está bajo investigación
el día de los veteranos es mañana es un
feriado aquí pero trabajaremos el
viernes trabajaremos el sábado y
trabajaremos el domingo para contar
estas boletas para que podamos pasar de
las 400.000 a 410.000 de las que todavía
estamos trabajando
manifestantes marcharon en apoyo al
presidente Pedro Castillo en la
denominada toma de Lima los
manifestantes rechazaron la tercera
moción de vacancia que buscan impulsar
contra el mandatario en el congreso la
tomada de Lima tiene el lugar tras una
protesta contra el gobierno de Castillo
que convocó acerca de 5000 personas en
el centro de la capital peruana
Francisco Zacarías desde Lima nos dio
más detalles de esta nutrida
manifestación
Esta es la denominada toma de Lima una
marcha que agrupa los incondicionales
del presidente Pedro Castillo ronda
campesinas federaciones agricultores y
colectivos de izquierda la movilización
busca apoyar la gobernabilidad y se
manifiesta en rechazo al congreso porque
considera que su labor es
obstruccionista Ojalá que sea un
gubernamental por su reiterados intentos
de vacancia El mandatario lo
manifestantes exigen a Pedro Castillo el
cierre del parlamento y se comprometa a
impulsar una asamblea Constituyente para
elaborar una nueva constitución por su
parte el congreso suspendió la sesión
del pleno de hoy para evitar que sus
trabajadores pudiesen resultar afectados
por efectos colaterales de la protesta
que se realiza en momentos en que
legislativo se encuentra en la etapa de
votación de un informe parlamentario que
recomienda una acusación por traición a
la patria al presidente Pedro Castillo
por haber ofrecido una salida al mar a
Bolivia durante una entrevista realizada
en enero de este año la independencia de
esta marcha está haciendo cuestionada
por diversos sectores varios medios
locales señalan que los organizadores se
reunieron en las últimas horas en
palacio de gobierno con el presidente
Pedro Castillo según un reporte oficial
para muchos es el propio Pedro Castillo
quien dirige la marcha
pasamos a Chile por primera vez desde
que ocupó el cargo el presidente Gabriel
borich visitó la región de la araucanía
que ha sido el epicentro de conflictos
entre el pueblo mapuche y el estado
chileno dicho territorio se encuentra en
estado de decepción hace más de cinco
meses con el objetivo de controlar la
situación de orden público los mapuches
la etnia indígena más numerosa de chile
reclama las tierras que habitaron
durante siglos Y que ahora pertenecen en
su mayoría a empresas de poderosos
grupos económicos previamente nuestra
corresponsal en Santiago Patricia Luna
no se explicaba la importancia del viaje
de borich a ese territorio
había sido una visita muy solicitada por
diversos sectores políticos también por
las diputados de esa región y había
mucha expectativa por parte
especialmente de las víctimas de la
violencia por personas que han tenido a
familiares a padres a hijos asesinados
por motivo de la violencia que se vive
en esa zona que sufren una escalada de
la violencia muy importante en los
últimos meses y en los últimos años
Aunque el conflicto Data de décadas
incluso podríamos decir que de siglos
Pero ha sido especialmente fuerte en los
últimos meses y estas víctimas pedían
justicia se va a reparar se va a
estudiar y revisar el programa de
reparación de las víctimas la agenda del
presidente ha estado muy cargada se ha
tratado de reunir con todos los actores
sociales en se ha trasladado en
helicóptero para poder alcanzar a llegar
a todos es una zona también marcada por
la pobreza es la región más pobre de
chile lo que se refleja en sus
carreteras en sus infraestructura
también en el acceso agua potable en de
sus escuelas donde los factores como la
pobreza y también factores Como por
ejemplo el robo de la madera o la
posesión de armas y también la seguridad
agroalimentaria son algunas de las
cuestiones que están encima de la mesa
además junto con el conflicto de
restitución de las tierras ancestrales
en Francia el presidente Manuel macron
recibió a varios líderes mundiales en el
Palacio del Eliseo en víspera del foro
por la paz que se celebra este viernes y
sábado en París entre ellos al
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro a
quien le manifestó el pleno apoyo de
Francia su proyecto de paz total macron
también se reunió con su homólogo
argentino Alberto Fernández y le
agradeció por su papel de mediador en la
crisis venezolana que será tema de
discusión en un encuentro entre
representantes del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro y la oposición Qué significa por
el gobierno venezolano que los diálogos
sean respaldados por los gobiernos que
lo desconocieron como líder de su país
se lo consultamos a Arturo peraza
abogado politólogo y vicerrector la
extensión guayana de la Universidad
Católica Andrés Bello en Venezuela
soy bueno lo hizo lo hizo también
prácticamente toda Europa yo sí creo que
en principio hay una suerte del
reconocimiento de la realidad política
venezolana que es compleja Es verdad que
Nicolás Maduro tiene un problema serio
de legisnidad pero al mismo tiempo es
cierto que el que está al frente del
gobierno y quien tiene el poder es
Nicolás maduro y el reconocer esa
realidad es parte de la necesidad de
establecer este camino de negociación y
diálogo para poder resolver la situación
interna venezolana y por el otro lado
estoy convencido que Europa quiere
liberarse del problema en el que se
hallado sometida con el punto energético
es decir evidentemente Venezuela es un
país exportador de petróleo capacidad
para exportar gas y Esta es una
necesidad en este momento en el ámbito
europeo por lo que es importante también
para Europa lograr un camino de solución
a fin de poder tener tener acceso a
estos recursos que en estos momentos Son
imprescindibles el panel
intergubernamental sobre el cambio
climático de las Naciones Unidas
advirtió el riesgo de que Europa sufra
pérdidas en la producción de cultivos
debido al calor continuado las
condiciones secas y el clima extremo
este informe es objeto de debate en la
copa 27 en Egipto y España es uno de los
países de más riesgo por lo que
industrias como la del vino tratan de
reinventarse los detalles con lluís
Muñoz
el vino mucho más que una bebida en
España amenazado ahora por la crisis
climática con cuatro años de descenso en
su producción cada vez a plantar a zonas
más altas luego pues montar regadíos
también porque al llover menos cada día
la planta necesita más agua en la
comunidad de La Rioja la Industria del
vino significa un 20% de la economía por
lo que existen lugares como el Instituto
de Ciencias de La Vid y el vino estoy
cogiendo aquí una hoja para luego hay
extraer en dna estudian los genomas de
las variedades de uva más utilizadas en
la región española han descubierto que
las viñas más antiguas de 35 años se
adaptan mejor al cambio climático porque
son genéticamente más diversas
esta tecnología que venimos usando en la
uva se ha utilizado principalmente para
la caracterización del genoma humano y
las enfermedades
algunas bodegas ya lo aplican como roda
pensamos en Buscar zonas más frías
dentro de La Rioja en este campo tienen
viñas viejas algunas de hasta 110 años
vemos que esta planta por ejemplo ya ha
sido vendimiada Pero antes de tiempo ha
empezado a secar sus hojas España es el
tercer productor de vino del mundo desde
las Naciones Unidas advierten del riesgo
de que Europa sufra pérdidas en la
producción de sus cultivos entre las
causas el aumento del calor España tuvo
el verano más caluroso desde que existen
registros con temperaturas 2,2 grados
centígrados por encima de la media
hasta aquí este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]